من البنتاجون ينضم الينا مراسل الجزيره
فادي منصور فادي اذا حزمه مساعدات عسكريه
جديده لاوكرانيا ذكرت بعض تفاصيلها
الزميله وجد ماذا عن التفاصيل الاخرى وما
ماذا يتوقع انفانتجون ان تحقيقه هذه
المساعدات على الارض
هي مدرعات برادلي وفقه مسؤول الامريكي
رفيع هنا لانه سوف تكون هذه الدفعه مؤلفه
من 50 مدرعه برادلي التي تحمل في الاساس
الرشاش المتوسط من عيار 25 ملم وهو مضاد
للافراد وعدد من المدرعات التدريع الخفيف
لكن البانتون يسمي هذه المدرعه بصائده
الدبابات لسبب وهو ما اكده المتحدث او
المسؤول الامريكي هنا لنا بان هذه
المدرعات سوف تكون مزوده بصواريخ تاو
المضاده للدبابات سوف تكون قادره على منح
القوات الاوكرانيه الافضليه في الميدان في
استهداف الدبابات الروسيه كما نعلم همم
مدرعه برادلي لديها طاقه للتسير من ثلاثه
افراد قائدها وايضا المسؤول عن التدخير
والذي يسير مدرعه وتستطيع ان تحمل سته
افراد من المشات على متنها لكن صواريخ او
تحمل قاذفتين لصواريخ تاو يصل مداها الى
اربعه الاف متر هذا المدى الفعال بمعنى
اربعه كيلومترات تستطيع ان تصيد الدبابات
الروسيه تمتلك سرعه عاليه وقادره على
المناوره واشار هذا المسؤول الامريكي لان
الولايات المتحده منفتحه على تزويد
اوكرانيا بمزيد من المدرعات ابراج
البنتاجون يعتبر ان هذا الامر سوف يمنح
القوات الاوكرانيه افضليه في الميدان سواء
في العمليات الهجوميه او في العمليات
الدفاعيه كما قال المتحدث باسم البانتون
تفاصيل الاساسيه المتعلقه بالحزمه سوف
يعلن عنها البنتاجون خلال مؤتمر صحفي يوم
الجمعه وسوف يوفر ايضا فيها تفاصيل تتعلق
بمنظومه التي سبق ان اعلن البنتاجون بانه
سوف يزود اوكرانيا بها المتحدث باسم البنت
رايدر اشار الى ان هناك خيارات متعدده
تتعلق في تدريب القوات الاو على هذه
المنظومه المتقدمه من بينها امكانيه تدريب
القوات الاوكرانيه هنا في الولايات
المتحده لكن بحسب ما علمنا ايضا ان
الولايات المتحده تعمل على وضع برنامج
لتدريب القوات الاوكرانيه على هذه
المنظومه بسرعه اكبر من المعتاد عاده
يتطلب التدريب على هذه البطاريه نحو عام
او اكثر الولايات المتحده تنظر في خيارات
تتعلق باشهر فقط لكي تكون قادره على نقل
هذه المنظومه الى الاراضي الاوكرانيه لكي
تستخدمها القوات الاوكرانيه في دفاعاتها
في الدفاع عن اجوائها المزيد من التفاصيل
بهذا الشان سوف تخرج ايضا خلال مؤتمر صحفي
في البنتاجون ننتظر ان ينعقد يوم الجمعه
لنعرف المزيد من التفاصيل شكرا